son décès la plongée dans l'oubli
antonio de la gandara disparaît en 1917
et laisse derrière lui des centaines
d'oeuvres ses descendants en expose 120
aujourd'hui au musée lambinet un travail
de vingt ans de recherches
tout ça ça a donné lieu à la rédaction
d'un ouvrage biographique en 2011 et
depuis 2011
en fait nous avons tous chercher les uns
les autres
un musée susceptibles d'accueillir
l'exposition rétrospective qui est elle
un petit peu le la chose nécessaire pour
que l'artiste revienne en pleine lumière
quelle belle artiste et quel dommage que
les musées ne l'est pas mis davantage en
valeur ces dernières années et comme il
y à un regain aujourd'hui de belles
époques un petit peu partout tant dans
le mobilier que dans l'expression
artistique de peinture notamment
on pense que la gandara toute sa place
aujourd'hui aux côtés de déborder ni
déjà camille blanche
antonio de la gandara débute par le
portrait à montmartre et dans les salons
mondains des portraits répartis dans les
huit salles du musée versailles et la
portée d'une oreille avait un lien avec
versailles parce qu'elle fréquentait
l'hôtel des réservoirs la ville
il la découvre en 1885 lors d'une
rencontre avec robert de montesquiou le
peindre tombe amoureux du parc et des
jardins de versailles la gandara à
versailles il retrouvait un peu de la
sérénité qui lui manquait lorsqu'il
avait ses modèles en pause continuelle
avec les cancans qu'il avait un subir et
puis les caprices de toutes ces dames
il trouvait donc dans le dans le concert
du jardin de versailles
des moments de repos de plénitude qui
lui permettait en même temps d'exercer
son art celui qui connut la gloire de
son vivant retrouve un peu de sa superbe
plus de cent ans après son décès antonio
de la gandara revient à versailles